on vous en parlait la semaine dernière
pour souligner la 50e saison de la
semaine verte
on va se permettre des petits détours
par nos archives
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en retour sur un moment
marquant de l'histoire des pêcheries
canadienne l'adoption de la zone des 200
milles marins
depuis toujours les européens pêche sur
les bancs de terre-neuve marins pêcheurs
d'espagne de france et d'ailleurs se
sont succédé de génération en génération
le poisson est ici abondant qu'on ne
voyait pas le jour où l'effort de pêche
menacerait sa survie pendant des siècles
seule une étroite bande de 3000 près des
côtes étaient considérés comme faisant
partie du territoire canadien
à partir des années 1950 l'arrivée de
bateaux usines provoque une hausse
insoutenable du volume des prises
la progression massive et incontrôlée de
la flotte étrangères était en réalité
une course vers la mort des pêcheries de
l'atlantique les pêcheurs côtiers
canadien se disputer les restes des
espèces dites traditionnelles comme la
morue le sébaste le flétan et l'aiglefin
c'est pour cette raison que dans les
années 1970 le gouvernement canadien
décide de prendre en main le contrôle
des pêcheries jusqu'à 200 milles marins
de ses comptes
première conséquence de cette politique
c'est que le nombre de navires pêchant
au large des côtes canadiennes a connu
une diminution brutale pour avoir la
permission de caché à l'intérieur d'une
zone ici il faut être membre des neuf et
puis il faut voir aussi un pari mais de
tâches qui est donnée par un canadien
adoptée en 1977 la limite des 200 milles
marins a été saluée par les pêcheurs
canadiens mais elle ne permettra pas de
freiner le déclin de nombreuses espèces